- On this episode, I get
really pissed at the lurkers.
(upbeat music)
♫ Gary Vee
♫ You ask questions
♫ And I answer them
♫ This is, the #AskGaryVee Show ♫
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this is episode 129
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
I'm in a good mood.
It's Friday?
- [Voiceover] Mhmm
Yes, it's Friday.
(people laugh)
Facebook Live, good to see you.
Excited getting to the weekend,
should be a lot of fun.
Got a couple of Wuzzles in the house.
Actually, you know what, DRock,
real quick, just shoot to right over there
to that little sign.
Just want people to take a look at that.
Just maybe because, super random.
The other thing I wanna do
before I get into the show
is to throw a dramatic
right hook here, right now.
I feel like a lot of the lurkers,
specifically watching in Facebook,
have not been leaving comments,
have not been coming out of the woodworks,
have not been saying hello, right?
I also feel that a lot of people
have been watching the show.
I see the numbers.
And the amount of comments
and shares and likes,
which then help me get distribution
in a Facebook, Newsfeed world,
are way too low.
As a matter of fact, Facebook
Live people right now,
if you're watching,
you can share, comment, and like.
Especially the share button.
I want more distribution.
I want the show to grow.
I'm throwing a right hook, Steve.
I mean, I think it's fair.
It's a free show.
I feel like I'm PBS.
I'm the modern PBS.
(people laughing)
Right?
I'm not charging.
I just need some support.
And the thing that's
really pissing me off,
is there are people actually,
this is backchannel information I have,
conversations I've had,
some random emails.
People actually are not sharing this show,
are not hitting the
share button right now.
That is a, yes, I want you
to hit the share button.
I'm gonna click that share button
and see every person that shared.
And anybody that didn't share
that I know has been watching the show,
I'm going to...
kill you.
Am I allowed to say that?
Would legal be a little
worried about that?
- Let's start again.
- Alright, you know what?
DRock, when I said, "Kill you" there,
put a little asterisk meaning,
"I'm just kidding I would never kill you".
(people laughing)
There are people that are
actually not sharing the show,
because they want to use the information
as their secret sauce.
Can you imagine?
- [Steve] I can pretty
easily imagine, yeah.
- Yeah, well that's 'cause you, you're--
- I'm not saying I'd do it,
I'm just saying it's not inconceivable.
- Oh no, I'm not saying that,
that's why you're saying it.
I'm saying it's because you're
cynical to the audience.
You actually hate the audience.
- You just took a really big leap
between those two statements, Gary.
- I'm just kidding.
But, share!
DRock, do something there.
Actually, you know what?
I want you to create something right now.
Edit this, and then
we'll use it all in time.
Share alert. (monster voice)
And when you edit it, DRock,
give fire and crazy stuff.
Share alert. (monster voice)
Share.
All right, India.
(people laughing)
You'll see what this all
was in a separate video
that DRock made me do.
I hate this.
We're definitely never doing this again.
Like, I'm doing something I hate.
I don't even do this at like, oh yeah!
India, let's get into the show.
Good talk, India.
- [India] All right, Clintus?
- Clintus.
- [Voiceover] Clintus asks,
"When you're business
is successfully growing,
"when do you start another?
"And how much time do you devote to it?"
- I think it comes down to
who you want to be as an operator.
Travis Kalanick, CEO of Uber,
really taught me a lesson
a couple years ago.
When Uber was starting to
take off, he became the CEO.
We did angel deals together,
and i was pinging him
about this hot angel deal.
And he said, "No, I don't
do angel deals anymore."
And then I pinged him about a talk.
And he says, "No, no I'm not gonna talk."
And it was just very focused.
And then he's basically
in that Bezos, Steve Jobs, Zucks mold,
which is, this is it.
This is it.
This is the job I'm gonna
do for the rest of my life,
and this is my career.
I already, clearly,
am on my second oofy business.
I think I've got two
more, three more in me.
And so, I'm gonna be an
entrepreneur that has,
you know, four or five businesses,
is my intuition, India.
Clintus.
And so, I think it comes
down to who you are, right?
And what you want.
Like, what's the size level of a business
that gets you to go
into a different place?
I mean, VaynerMedia
next year, revenue wise,
is going to substantially,
probably pass Wine Library's
biggest year of revenue.
So I'll be going into new territory.
Am I an entrepreneur that likes
that 50-100 million dollar revenue place,
then I go away?
Or am gonna see?
It really just comes down to a lot
of different circumstances.
I do think that you need
to question, the question.
Which means, if you're already
asking me this question
and thinking about going
on to the next thing,
you need to figure out
how much you love the
current thing at all.
Are you just trying to pass it away?
I think there's a more
interesting insight to that.
I think everybody who's watching the show,
needs to think about,
are they happy with their business?
There's businesses that you
could be making $200,000 a year in,
that could be holding you back.
'Cause it's a ton of money,
you might just not like it.
And so, I think there's the like factor.
For me, I will run this
business, VaynerMedia,
as CEO, as long as I love it.
That's really the answer.
I mean, I'm glad I got to stick here,
because I kind of used a financial proxy
as the justification.
But to me, as long as I
love it, I mean it could be.
But my intuition tells me
I've got a couple more.
So, I think it comes down to you.
And I think it also comes
down to infrastructure.
If Brandon Warnke and Justin
Novello and Bobby Shifrin
and John Kassimatis and Bryan
Delatorre and Geoff Thurose,
if they weren't in place at Wine Library,
along with my dad,
I would still be there.
VaynerMedia, I mean, some of
you have been here for awhile.
VaynerMedia is a helluva
lot better shape today
for me not be around,
than it was a year ago.
I mean, a helluva lot.
We've gotten dramatically more senior.
People have grown.
But, I think it's still
maybe a couple of years away
before I feel like it can
sustain and grow without me.
And so, the practicality of
this decision matters as well.
India, wait a minute, how
did we not talk about this?
Because we talk about it in real life.
You know, Vayner Nation.
Look at this.
I mean, India, talk about
kissing up to the boss, Stunwin.
(people laughing)
She got dizzy.
India's gonna go to a lot
of Jet games this year.
I'm taking her to a lot of games.
- [India] First football game.
- That's crazy India.
- [India] I know.
Side question of the day-
how many football games have
you been to in your life?
I just wanna see how many
goose eggs there are.
Hashtag team India.
All right.
- [India] This is from my dad, John.
- What did you say?
- This question's from my dad.
- This question's from your dad?
- The best part about this
is, your email to me is like,
you think it's okay to take
the question from your dad?
You're such a, I really like your morals.
- Oh, thank you.
- It would've been really, really funny
if you had just asked
it and said, from John,
and just like slipped it in there.
All right, India's dad.
- [Voiceover] India's dad asks,
"How do I succinctly explain
who you are and what you do
"to people who don't know
and aren't new media savvy?"
- How do I do that?
- [India] How would you
explain it to someone?
- Me?
Oh man, I wish this was
the ask Lizzy Vee Show.
My life, my wife, she is my life.
My wife thinks this is the...
it is literally her favorite thing.
'Cause we know, we go
to a lot of functions
and meet a new couple.
And they're like, so what do you do?
And she just gets a kick out of it,
because I think your dad,
who's got some context of me
at this point,
recognizes it's not that easy.
It's a long-winded answer.
At this point I do say
that I'm an entrepreneur.
I think it just saves time.
But then there's a part
of me that feels like
that's a fluffy kind of answer.
And so, I also lately,
that's actually not true.
I was going entrepreneur for awhile.
But right now, lately, I'm very hard core,
I'm a CEO of a large
social digital agency.
And I'm the lead partner
in a $25 million venture fund.
And I'm also the host of
the #AskGaryVee Show.
I don't say that yet,
but I stuck it in the other day.
I love talking about myself,
so I always love that question
and I drag it out for as long
as they'll keep listening.
But that's what I've
been doing at this point.
Oh that's cool.
That's an amazing picture.
- All right, DRock I'm sure
you're editing that in perfectly?
Great job.
- [Sid] digitaljeff asks,
"How important is it to love the product
"that your company sells?
"Would you hire someone that
had never used your product?
"And can being too much in
love with your own product
"work against you?"
- To me,
we're talking about
from a sales standpoint?
I think that this is probably the--
(crackling)
- [DRock] Yeah, battery just died.
Get some new batteries real quick.
- You be cool, but this
is rolling the whole time.
Now, are they picking it up on the--
- [Voiceover] Yep.
- They're picking this all up, right?
So this is all rolling in
black and white, right?
This is all black and white, right?
- [Voiceover] Yep.
- [Gary] Okay, good.
(people laughing)
- All right Vayner Nation,
let's do something secret.
I've got a big idea.
Let's all hit up @DRock on Twitter, right?
Oh he sees this, he edits.
Fuck it.
I'm so pissed.
Oh, I've got Facebook Live.
Eat crap, DRock.
All right, Facebook Live.
How many people are watching?
- [Voiceover] Uh, 1,800.
- Perfect, 1,800.
I want all 1,800 of you
to do the following thing;
What's DRock's thing?
At DRockNYC?
- [Voiceover] Go back out.
- [India] Can you
get me a glass of water?
- Yeah, we're kicking you out
so we can do something, DRock.
(people laughing)
- [Steve] at David Rock NYC.
- David Rock?
or DRock?
- [Sid] Someone else has DRock.
- [Steve] David Rock, David Rock.
- David Rock, @davidrocknyc.
Just hit him up with
like, hashtag audio fail.
And then a wink and a love,
'cause he's the best guy.
- All right, DRock, where are ya?
- [India] I think he actually
went to go get me water.
(people laughing)
- He's the best guy.
All right, back to you
guys in black and white.
Oh DRock, I love it.
He's so sad.
He's so great.
Like, he has so much pride
in skills, but he uh--
[India] He's got my water.
He's so cute.
Thank you so much.
- This is a classic.
This is the Golden Era.
I love it.
(Hallelujah music)
- Batteries.
At least it's just batteries.
You know, you can't worship batteries.
Antonio Allen was just
cut by the New York Jets.
One of my favorite players
of all time in New York,
number 39.
He was cut.
'Cause of the injury.
It's tough.
It's a rough game.
So Antonio, thank you so much
for the years in green and white.
Number 39, much love.
Okay, lets...I don't know where I was,
'cause DRock ruined the show.
- [Voiceover] Let's give that another try.
digitaljeff asks, "How important
is it to love the product
"that your company sells?
"Would you hire someone that
had never used your product?
"And can being too much in
love with your own product
"work against you?
- Yes.
I would tell you that it's the
single most important thing.
I think the reason that
I'm a great salesman
is that I really, fundamentally
believe in everything
that I'm selling.
The advice here, my books,
wine that I recommend.
I'm about to an Instagram
wine offer for the first time
in a coupon.
Right after we tape this.
I really believe in this Rosé.
I know, it's a little side thing.
Sorry, Steve.
Steve's my wine boss.
And so, hash tag wine boss.
Show him and show hashtag wine boss.
Love it.
So, we cookey here on Friday.
Really your fault DRock
for the battery thing.
And so, I can't wait for the edit of this.
Share. (monster voice)
Remember the oak monster?
DRock, the Share Monster. (monster voice)
When the share monster comes out,
you have to stop what you're doing
and hit the share button on Facebook.
All of you online, you
have to do that right now.
Sid the intern, have them
say, yes they just did it,
and see how many yes's you got.
And if you don't count
1,900 to match the thing,
start yelling and getting crazy in there.
You have to sell what you believe in.
The reason salesmanship has a bad name
is because 98% of
salespeople don't believe
in what they're actually selling.
They're just going for the commission.
The money is what drives them,
not the pride and the lifetime value
of selling something good.
When you sell something you believe in,
you get so much more money out of it,
because people come back.
Guys, it's all about the
second and third and fourth
and fifth and sixth and
seventh and eighth and ninth
and tenth and eleventh
and twelfth and thirteenth
and fourteenth and fifteenth and sixteenth
and seventeenth and
eighteenth and nineteenth
and twentieth sale.
Not the first one.
And what happens is,
if you actually really believe
in what you're selling,
it gives you more conviction and belief
that you're gonna get that sale.
And I believe in that tremendously.
I think that's why I
think a great salesperson
is somebody that truly
believes and are passionate
about what she or he sells,
is the number one kind
of person in the world.
And that's what I focus on.
And so, I think it is the
prerequisite to being successful.
The way you think your
children are the most beautiful
and the smartest,
that's the blind faith
you have to be having
in what you sell.
Oh, there's a part two of the question?
- [India] Can you be
too much in love with?
- No!
- [India] No? Okay.
- No.
Blind faith, India.
- [India] All right, it's
from Kelsey Humphreys.
- Okay, Kelsey.
Great background.
Great lipstick.
- Hey Gary Vee.
It's Kelsey Humphreys,
we are taking a quick break
from shooting The Pursuit,
and I thought I would send you a question.
But I have to say, you are killing me.
Because I keep recording questions for you
and then I go to post it
and you already posted
like, three new episodes
and four long Facebook posts,
and you answered my question.
So I hope that this question
makes it into the Golden Era.
- [Gary] Oh, that's a real fan.
- My question is about having
two different audiences,
and how you juggle them.
For example, the audience for #AskGaryVee
is very different from your ideal client
from VaynerMedia.
- [Gary] Good observation.
And for me, I get a lot
of opt-ins and traction
and comments from my audience
when I talk about how I'm still a rookie,
and my show's only six months old,
and I'm still figuring out what I'm doing.
They love that.
But, I'm worried about potential guests
and potential sponsors not
wanting to work with someone,
whose content is about
how they're a rookie.
And I think a lot of people deal with this
when they're trying to
take their client base
to the next level,
but the content that
they've been putting out
is on the previous level.
So, tell us what to do about that, Gary.
Thanks.
- You got it, Kels.
This is a very easy
question to answer for me.
The answer is, the part
where I sell for clients,
I'm selling them the
services of VaynerMedia.
In the beginning my ability,
now our agency's ability,
to help use social media
to drive business results.
And that's just a separate
entire conversation
from the content of the show
that is helping a lot of entrepreneurs.
And this is not made for
branch managers and CMOs
of Fortune 500s,
other than the ones that
are passionately pursuing
other interests maybe financially,
or thinking about outside
the corporate environment.
And so, this skews more
entrepreneurial things
in that nature.
I think that you can't
be crippled by that.
it sounds like to me, in
that way you asked it,
it was a great question.
My curiosity is, are you using the show
as a gateway drug to clients?
That's where your rub is.
For me, I'm not using this show as that.
And so, I'm not concerned about having-
they're very church and state.
If you view that what
you're doing on this show,
or how you're going about it,
is the same service that you're
then selling to a client,
well then you've got a problem.
Because you're admitting to them
that you're only so far along the way.
And so, me being a personality
around business questions
is very different than
me being an operating CEO
of a large scale social and digital shop
that helps clients execute
creative and strategy
in those channels.
It ties in a little bit,
because I use my tactics like the--
Share Monster (monster voice)
is there like fire coming out?-
to learn what that means and then maybe,
a Dove Soap or a Toyota
can then use those tactics
to make those things happen.
But, I think that's the disconnect.
- [India] Only one you need.
- Only one you need.
- [India] Instead of doing forums,
you talked about forums...
- [Gary] Yeah.
- You're the only one I need.
I need.
Do you notice what I said?
You're the only one I need.
I'm amazing.
(people laughing)
Mom, you really brainwashed
the shit out of me.
(people laughing)
Self-esteem for days.
- [Voiceover} OnlyOneYouNeed asks,
"Instead of doing a forum,
have you considered doing
a private Facebook group
for the Ask Gary Vee Show?
- Oh, that's a great idea.
It's something that I haven't done.
I noticed one of the fans
jumped in and created one.
It's something that's run through my mind.
And actually, i think this question
is gonna spur me to do it.
So, at the end of the
Golden Era, in episode 131,
we will announce a private Facebook group
just so I can test it.
That's some work for you guys.
Cool, great question.
All right, hope you have a great weekend.
Question of the day is,
what are your weekend plans lurkers?
If you don't know what a lurker is,
if you didn't watch Wine Library TV.
A lurker is someone who
watches this god damn show,
cyphens all the information for free,
for themselves,
and doesn't have that gene in their body
to know that I am feeding off of,
not cash.
I am feeding off of engagement,
content, shareability,
all these nice things.
And so, lurkers, please
come out this weekend,
that sits the whole time.
Please come out.
YouTube lurkers, all of you.
Podcast lurkers, whoever review them.
Lurkers, you're pissin' me off.
That's a right hook,
heavy #AskGaryVee Show.
You keep asking questions,
and commenting, or I
won't answer them anymore.
I'm really, I think you guys
are getting my tone here, right?
I'm pissed.
The lurkers,
they're like Patriot fans.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
Hey Andy.
What's he doing?
He looks like he's being very
serious looking at his phone.
(people laughing)
Oh I keep crushing Andy's head.
Ha ha, I got you Andy.
Crushing your head.
Amazing.
(upbeat music)